welcome back to curious archive this
video is the finale of my two-part
series of the biology of the video game
subnautica below zero
deeper within this alien ocean
astonishing ecosystems shocking
mysteries and chilling terrors still
await discovery
and much like how the strangest life in
earth's oceans dwells in the abyss the
depths of sector zero open a whole new
world of surprises
i've also found it an even more
frightening place to do field work
and with the mysterious signal calling
out from the deep at the end of the last
video who knows what final secrets
planet 4546b is hiding so join me on the
last section of our documentary style
voyage as we conclude this expedition
into the unknown
the mysterious transmission is emanating
from the murky waters of a region known
as the deep twisty bridges
diving into these alien depths the only
light comes from the bioluminescent
coral bridges that spiral throughout
this cavernous abyss
the dimness of the deep has transformed
all life that swims in the gloom
like pale ghosts the skeletal spine fish
haunt these depths a subspecies of the
hoopfish the spinefish had become nearly
translucent and possess rib-like
markings that give them a deathly
appearance the phenomenon of certain
deep-sea fish becoming transparent is
present in earth's oceans as well
notably in the barrel eye fish an animal
that possesses a head made of
translucent tissue to allow it to look
upwards and spot its preferred prey
right through the top of its head
truthfully the barrel eye fish is an
animal that would seem right at home in
the oceans of planet 4546p
but the spinefish isn't a carnivore so
despite its haunting appearance it's no
real danger
but there are genuine dangers here a
huge predator swims torpedo-like among
the bridges
with unexpected speed it rushes in and
attempts to swallow me whole a fate i'm
barely able to avoid by prying its jaws
open the predator continues to give
chase but i escape by swimming into a
crevice it can't reach
that terror of the abyss was a squid
shark a highly aggressive fauna species
that is the apex predator of this region
analysis suggests its terrifying bursts
of speed come from two vents on either
side of his body which provide jet
propulsion through this adaptation the
squid shark like its name suggests
combines the most formidable aspects of
deep sea squids and macro predator shark
species the result is a deadly
amalgamation i'll have to keep a wide
distance from if i ever want to find the
source of the transmission
staying close to the ocean floor a
curious waving plant catches my eye
swimming in for a closer look the
lifeworm lashes out with a long tendril
and pulls me towards a mouth-like
opening
after a few frantic punches the creature
releases his tentacle and i swim out of
range
that was a spiky trap which isn't
actually a plant at all but a highly
unusual form of animal this carnivorous
life form blends into the terrain
camouflaging itself among vegetation and
catching fish and unwary explorers with
its adhesive tendrils when they swim too
close
and despite its lack of mobility this
strategy seems to be highly effective
in the deep twisty bridges one must
always stay alert
elsewhere on the sea floor i discover a
strange glowing device near the signal
source this ruined fragment matches the
strange structures present in the
tropics which belong to a group of alien
architects i'd assumed all the
architects had perished but with the
signal beckoning me onwards i wonder if
i was mistaken
at last i reach a mysterious undersea
facility as i navigate through the halls
an unknown voice urges me to hurry
entering a central chamber i find both
the signal and the voice have been
coming from this cube-shaped computer
the voice turns out to be that of an
architect who thousands of years before
had stored his consciousness within the
computer speaking through the cube the
architect explains he was a scientist
like me and is now likely the last of
his kind wanting to help a fellow
researcher i offer to transfer the
lonely consciousness to my field
computer and take him with me on my
expedition the architect accepts and
warns me to brace for transfer
a little too late i realized something
might have been lost in translation
awakening with a mild headache i can
hear the architect's voice quite clearly
and learn this is because he downloaded
himself directly into my brain it was an
honest mistake as architects don't
recognize a boundary between technology
and the body while this is an intriguing
revelation about architect biology it
means i now have an unanticipated mental
roommate
returning to the shallows we formulate a
plan we'll use our combined knowledge to
continue to chart the biology of life in
sector zero but along the way we'll
gather the material needed to fabricate
a body that my new friend can transfer
into
he tells me his designation is a-l-a-n
so i'll call him alan
picking up where alan's research left
off we venture to the sprawling expanse
of the west arctic
here great icebergs float above a
seemingly bottomless region of the sea
creating a profound sense of scale
and among these giant icebergs swim
undiscovered oddities
gliding through the blue is an animal
that is difficult to unravel with two
sets of wing-like fins it's not clear
what sort of life form we're observing
at a glance
but this life form is in fact an arctic
ray the first of many race species in
sector zero while its body plan has
clearly diverged from earth rays by
having four wing structures instead of
two the arctic ray is a highly agile
life form
and it has to be if it wants to avoid
the top predator of the west arctic this
is a pinnacared an intelligent and
social predator that spends half its
time on ice floats above the water
pinocarids have converged on an
ecological niche similar in many
respects to earth seals and are
remarkably friendly towards humans even
showing acute curiosity when lured in
with a tasty piece of fish
allen's analysis suggests their 14
flippers make them acrobatic hunters
underwater
this unusually high number of flippers
resembles the anatomy of anomalocarids
a group from earth's cambrian period who
similarly possessed multiple fins for
locomotion
descending deeper into the west arctic
waters what appears to be a legion of
pulsating eyes stare back at us this is
in fact a colony of eye jellies
gelatinous lifeforms that harbor an
enormous hemispheric eye on the tops of
their bodies
despite their somewhat alarming
appearance these creatures live
remarkably passive lives drifting slowly
on the currents in vast colonies paying
little mind to other species alan notes
that they are capable of releasing a
small electric shock if we swim too
close however so we'll give the group a
wide berth
upon one of the west arctic icebergs we
notice an entrance to a small cave
venturing inside the reflected ice
caught in the afternoon sun resembles
the brilliance of the night sky
and within this ethereal cave a strange
egg appears stranded on a cave wall
it's not a species alan recognizes and
it seems about ready to hatch
bringing the egg to the warmth of the
shallows after some time this creature
emerges the unusual hatchling turns out
to be a tri-valve and much like the
cuttlefish of the tropics it's a
remarkably friendly and intelligent
creature that is quite a fan of treats a
scan suggests the body of this naturally
inquisitive life form is made of a
flexible exoskeleton and somewhat
resembles the shell of an earth nautilus
in its shape it's tempting to relax in
the shallows with the tri-valve for
longer but alan reminds me we still have
other areas to chart
and the next leg of the journey will be
perilous indeed luckily i have a new
classification of submersible to aid in
the voyage
this is a sea truck an underwater
vehicle that will allow us to go lower
into the crushing depths of sector zero
than ever before
at the helm of the sea truck we venture
into the vast biome of the thermal zone
the edge of this region an area known as
the thermal spires is marked by a forest
of hydrothermal vents
these chimney-shaped structures are
formed from dissolved minerals pushed up
from the planet's crust and are home to
all kinds of remarkable life
gliding between the vents is a brightly
colored feather fish
defined by their unusual crescent-shaped
fin structure feather fish are one of
the more graceful herbivores in sector
zero a highly successful species in some
regions they gather in schools numbering
in the thousands
we are admiring one such school when an
intimidating creature paddles by this
vicious looking armored predator is a
cryptosucus and is covered in sharp
spines snapping wildly it closes in
and then retreats just as quickly
as it turns out the contrarian
cryptosucus is one species where its
bark is truly worse than its bite while
it appears fearsome a scan suggests its
menacing shell is adapted to aid in heat
absorption among the thermal vents and
so this false tyrant paddles away to try
and scare off something a bit smaller
far deeper into the thermal zone the
dark blue of a biome known as the tree
spires beckons these waters are lit by
the bioluminescent flora that grow on
the sides of tree-like hydrothermal
vents
in this distinctive region the equally
distinctive discus fish undulates along
its flat semi-transparent body is highly
unusual and it seems to contain strange
green organs a study of the discus fish
reveals this green color comes from
symbiotic algae-like organisms living
within specialized body cavities that
provide the discus fish with food
strange as this might sound emerald sea
slugs of earth also photosynthesize
using algae that grows within their
bodies since there isn't much sunlight
here in the depths for plant growth it's
likely the discus fish spends part of
its life cycle in a brighter region of
sector zero
elsewhere in the thermal zone we can
spot a teardrop shaped arrow ray this
ray species has an elongated body and a
rather triangular head which it can tilt
to perform unpredictable maneuvers at
the ends of the aero rays fins grow
sharp talon-like tips that deter
attackers who manage to catch up meaning
the aero ray certainly isn't defenseless
a huge life form passes in front of our
submarine without warning it shrieks and
latches onto the windshield with its
front mandibles gunning the engine i'm
barely able to twist out of the deadly
grip that leviathan class organism was a
chalicerate a brute that grows over 130
feet or 30 meters in length its body is
covered in a thick segmented exoskeleton
that grows in overlapping plates which
may offer protection from the
atmospheric pressure since the
chelycerate are so aggressive and
potentially deadly they're a challenging
species to study up close fascinating as
they are we both hope we don't encounter
any more of them
at the very bottom of the sea floor an
indescribably massive life form is
waiting this is a vent garden a
stationary leviathan that anchors itself
above hydrothermal vents and consumes
100 of the nutrients they release at
over 360 feet or 110 meters the vent
garden is by far the largest leviathan
of sector zero the only things in
earth's oceans that resemble vent
gardens are certain types of
siphonophores soft-bodied entities which
like the vent gardens are also
technically colonies of smaller
organisms working in tandem but what's
most incredible about the vent garden is
the internal ecosystem of plants it
supports within its hollow bell-shaped
center and remarkably a scan indicates
it would be safe to enter this
environment ourselves
exiting the submarine we tentatively
swim up towards the light and at last
emerge within the microcosm of the vent
garden
this mini ecosystem supports aquatic
flora on branching platforms that in
turn help absorb some of the heavy
metals emitted by the vents below
exploring the hidden biosphere of event
garden is a downright magical experience
but the unknown still beckons
pushing further into the abyss than ever
before we've reached the edge of the
habitable region for most fauna
surrounded by total darkness alan is
starting to get worried that we've
strayed too far
and he seems to be right a huge
chalicerate emerges from the blackness
almost twice the size as the one from
the tree spires this pale mutation is
called avoid chelicerate and it's not
alone we've stumbled into a pack
time to head back as fast as we possibly
can
i don't think either of us plan on
revisiting this area anytime soon
returning to the safety of the research
base i have with alan's help given our
station a bit of an upgrade as it turns
out having an alien scientist downloaded
into your brain can be quite useful and
while alan still doesn't understand the
purpose of basic things like music or
why i start every morning with coffee
together we've successfully mapped much
of sector zero yet a deep scan tells us
there's a strange signature coming from
a large ice cave we've yet to visit
the cave is far to the inland of sector
zero
at last we enter the cavern and discover
an enormous frozen creature encased in a
cave wall
this leviathan-class organism has been
entombed here for thousands of years as
alan remembers encountering their kind
when he was a researcher here long ago
since this species is hopefully now
extinct the only way to study it is to
drill into the ice
taking a dna sample from the creature's
foot i'm able to determine the life form
was quadrupedal and spent at least a
portion of its time on land something
unusual for planet 4546b
perhaps this frozen leviathan suggests
an era in the distant past where land
was more plentiful and great titans like
this one roamed across it in any case
i'm certainly glad this particular
specimen is now long dead i think
at long last we now have all the
necessary materials needed to fabricate
alan's new body the only problem is that
the one architect facility that can
create such a compatible vessel is
located in a region known as the crystal
caves these caverns are the deepest
biome of them all and the last frontier
of planet 4546b
and since the refractive crystals mean
any scans of the region come back
fragmented there's no telling what else
is down there
navigating the purple chasm this
environment possesses a strange beauty
and equally strange life forms can be
found in these depths
the triops is a tiny organism that
spends much of its time hiding from
predators in the surrounding terrain
the triops stand out biologically
however thanks to their distinctive
three-eyed ocular system in nature a
life-form evolving three distinct eyes
isn't particularly common but it's not
altogether unheard of artemia is a genus
of aquatic crustaceans that possess two
eyes mounted on flexible stalks and a
third stationary eye situated in the
center of their head
so the diminutive triops is in good
company
further into the planet's crust we've
arrived at the fabricator caves a
secondary layer of the crystal caves
where a high concentration of the
element beryllium led to the formation
of striking red crystals
to brave this extreme geochemical
environment i've donned the prawn suit a
deep sea mechanical walker that kept me
safe on the last stages of my journey in
the tropics stomping along the ocean
floor i spot a small crustacean nearby
given its diminutive stature i'm not
particularly worried until it launches
itself at my prawn suit this is a rock
puncher a pint-sized predator which is a
heavy hitter nonetheless its hardened
claws can thrust forward at close to the
speed of sound to break rock and bone
alike in many respects the rock puncher
is similar to the precocious mantis
shrimp these creatures possess
spring-loaded biological hammer clubs
that can strike prey faster than the
speed of a bullet giving the mantis
shrimp the ability to truly punch above
its weight class and the rock puncher is
no different time to de-escalate the
situation by moving elsewhere
we're now very close to the fabrication
facility when a thunderous roar shakes
the cavern
a huge leviathan grips my prawn suit and
pulls me towards a glowing gullet after
smacking it with my prawn suit's arms
the nightmare serpent temporarily drops
me
backing into a narrow gap it seems the
leviathan cannot follow we're safe
for now
that was a shadow leviathan which at
almost 200 feet or 60 meters is the
single most dangerous predator of sector
zero its elongated body gives this
monster the appearance of a giant eel
analysis suggests its bioluminescent
digestive tract glows due to
light-seeking phytoplankton that draw in
unwary fish and its mouth also secretes
a highly acidic compound
we're lucky we were able to escape such
a terrifying life form unscathed
or have we
looking up i notice my prawn suit is
leaking from its fight with the shadow
leviathan
our only hope now is to reach the
fabrication facility before the shadow
finds me again
but with the familiar green glow of
architect technology up ahead at last
we've reached the ultimate destination
heading inside i find a facility quite
like the one i first discovered allen
within putting in the materials we've
gathered the facility begins the process
of fabrication
activating the final sequence alan and i
watch as the vessel is constructed this
new body is composed of the dna of 27
different species and various inorganic
materials as well so it should be quite
the upgrade at last alan's body is
complete after so much effort it's
almost surreal to reach this point i
think about telling my friend he looks a
bit like a glowing purple centaur but
decide that would probably just confuse
him with alan now out of my mind and
settled into his new vessel he doesn't
need my assistance to continue his
research
we both returned to the surface and alan
informs me he'll be going back to his
home planet via warp gate to see if
there are any other architects still
living it is a somewhat bittersweet
feeling as i realize this is goodbye
working with another researcher in
particular an alien one has been a
special privilege
alone on planet 4546b once more i
consider all i've seen on this wondrous
planet from nerve-wracking dangers to
unexpected allies it's been a remarkable
journey but now at last the time has
come for me to depart as well
for who knows what else is waiting among
the stars
if you enjoyed discovering the creatures
of subnautica below zero please follow
and support creature designer alex reese
using the links below
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you